John starts us off this hour and
Cookeville Tennessee welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show John Thank You mr. Ramsey
how're you doing better than I deserve
what's up so here's my issue right now
me and my wife are about $35,000 in debt
and just like any normal person we
decided to finally get our right our
Lobster out and start working on this
bed right in the middle of having a baby
so what I've been doing with is I'm a
full-time firefighter and I've been
working that job and another job on top
of some things on the side pretty much
just to keep us getting by mm-hmm my
wife just had our daughter in February
and you just found a job as a nurse yeah
we're super excited just found a job as
a nurse and I'm having a real problem
I'm just want some advice from Uncle
Dave my wife got the job mainly so I
wouldn't have to work three jobs just to
keep us treading water mmm but a part of
me is having problems letting go of that
second job because in my mind if I
worked that second job we'll get out of
debt quicker but it is it has been a
strain on us and I did forget to mention
I'm also in school full-time so it's
it's been a bit of a hectic home life
for a while and I just I'm trying to let
this second job go but at the same time
I don't know if I should concentrate on
this and get this debt knocked out or
you know I just I'm just looking for
some advice gotcha
okay what do you make as a fireman my
salary is about $34,000 years okay you
get overtime as a fireman uh it is very
situational the way our overtime works
is there's only overtime when we are
super low on personnel and it's it's
very infrequent time so 34,000 we count
on what is she making is a nurse now
right now she's gonna be making on
average somewhere around $1,800 a month
and this is just starting like last week
okay so she's not working forty hours
she is working forty hours it's just low
pay she's a LP she's an LPN and she's
gonna be making 1150 an hour that's a
little pay for an LPN it is but we
almost twenty places you know this isn't
some lack of trying this is the first
place that we give an interview as crazy
as that found alright so we're gonna
call that twenty four for the fun of it
and so then what were you making it this
at the second you dropped the third job
that one's out the only one we're
discussing is the second job what are
you making it the second job so with the
second job
I brought before tax it was around
$12,000 last year is what I made and
that was working I'm sorry about a
thousand dollars a month okay yeah yeah
roughly and so what are you doing
what's the second job I'm working
actually at a doctor's office in a
paramedic role pretty much acting as a
nurse I I'm making about 16 dollars an
hour doing that but it's it's hard to do
that full-time jobs which is a 24 on 48
off leave that go to the doctor's office
leave that go to school and it's it's it
seems like you know I've got barely
enough time to breathe most the time
which is why she decided to leave the
home and go back to work
okay well the trick is on 58,000 on your
all's budget how quick are you going to
clear the 35 if you're not working the
second job see that's a that's my hope
and here's here's what I'm really
talking about it is my plan was to be
able to pay this off at anywhere between
18 and 24 months depending on able do
that without the second job okay
you so you think we'll be safe with that
I just I hate to be invest that long you
know I think you I build it in 18 to 24
I mean that's 17,500 a year is 24 months
on 35,000 and then and making 58 y'all
will do 17 a year and that ought to be a
lay down you gotta do it faster than
that so somewhere between really twelve
and eighteen it ought to be done out of
your 58 get on beans and rice rice and
beans budget right 35 is your only dad
other than your home if you don't have
if you didn't forget to tell me about a
car payment or something but I know
that's car payments and everything it
feels like a lot more to me I guess
because for so long we were living on
just my salary
yeah you bet on your income just doubled
almost right brag which is a huge relief
I dunno I've worked the second job for
so long it's hard for me to let go what
I don't know but the point is my point
is I don't I'm not gonna let you let it
go either if it if it benefits your
family substantially you know but the
deal is they're gonna be debt-free in 12
to 24 mar 12 2014 1 2 3 4 the good of
your family for the good of the child
and you know you're setting a tone that
you're gonna you're not gonna live like
this anymore you know we're gonna get
our our incomes up and we're going to
get rid of all this debt and we're going
to get our life back and you're you know
you're scratching and clawing and doing
it so you're the kind of people we're
here to help you know and it's what we
want you to do so I'm proud of you I
think you're doing good work thanks for
the call